US government asked Banks to flag
private transactions including Maga or
Trump purchases of Bibles this is this
is this is wild the US government asked
financial institutions to filter private
customer purchases using terms including
Maga Trump as part of a January 6
investigation perhaps most shockingly
they also asked for a warning uh of
purchases of religious texts including
the Bible that could indicate extremism
according to the letter from uh to the
former director of the financial crimes
enforcement Network work Noah Bishoff
from the house Judiciary Committee and
its subcommittee on the weaponization of
the federal government house Judiciary
Committee uh chair Jim Jordan posted the
letter on X the platform formerly known
as Twitter writing we now know the
federal government flag terms like Maga
and Trump okay so we we don't need to
read the quote we know it he also says
if you were shopping at Bass Pro Shop
this doesn't seem uh in my opinion like
they're just trying to find criminals it
seems more like they are building a
profile database they're going to have a
list of look man we often joke that
Facebook knows when you poop and the
reason I bring that up is because it
brings a little levity levity to the
situation but we are entering the era of
pre-crime you guys ever SE you've seen
my Minority Report right I love this
movie because it's like I think it's a
Philip K dick uh uh uh uh novel or story
and then it get turns into a movie and
the idea is they have they get they get
lucky in the DC area they find three
psychics and they plug them into a
machine and then the psychics can
predict murder
the reality is you don't need psychics
you don't need magic they have built
these databases that track what you do
what you say when you say it and they
are building databases and profiles and
predictive machines and it's not just
about whether you've done anything wrong
it's whether or not you are a threat to
their proposed order so the reality here
is it's actually quite simple aren't
they going to come knock on your door
and arrest you because you bought a
Bible or went to Bass Pro Shop no but uh
are you going to get denied that loan
for your small business yes are you
going to going to get higher points for
your uh your interest rates when you
when you try to buy a house yes are you
going to fail when you are your kids
going to be rejected from certain
schools it's going to be subtle they're
not going to come outright and be like
we reviewed your score and the federal
government spying on you find out
finding out that you went to the bass
proops no they're going to be like okay
let's try and see if you're AA you're uh
uh the loan we can get you a loan on
that house and you've been denied and
you'll say why like you know it just
says you've been rejected sorry have a
nice day and it's GNA be because of
things like this so this made me think
of uh one of the uh things that I saw
right after the uh an announcement of
the the Iowa caucuses Joy Reed came
right out and said you know look at all
of those white Christians in Iowa and it
was just demonizing people because of
their religion and because of the color
of their skin there's not and there's
there's no mincing words about it
anymore it is clearly and openly she was
I think she was talking about whether or
not
uh people would go for Nikki Haley and I
and I think that that that was the in
the cont that's the context of
mentioning but even still um you know
the idea that they're talking about
people that bought Bibles you know
they're going to start focusing on
religious people and they're going to
start making people that have any kind
of religion uh that is not approved by
the state um they're going to you're
you're going to demonize people and it's
not going to be social credit score it's
everything yeah you're going to get
you're going to get pulled over more
so when there's a uh people are getting
screened at airports it's going to be
things like this you're going to go to
the airport and you're going to be going
through and they're going to be like
you're fine you're fine uh you uh the
alarm went off that this happened to me
during Occupy Wall Street it happened to
uh James o'keef this is funny with James
he gets the four s's on his uh boarding
pass and then people are like yo they're
saying you're like a terror threat that
was really funny because you know during
Occupy Wall Street when I was traveling
the same thing happened to me I'd have
four S's and they actually I I kid you
not they stole a USB drive from me and
had nothing on it it's just really weird
that what pissed me off the most about
it is that it was really expensive back
then these like high like we were
talking 10 years ago if you wanted to
get like 128 GB USB flash drive I mean
these are like $100 plus super expensive
and so I have it in my bag
I'm going through security they stop me
and say you've been randomly chosen for
a screening and I'm like that's not true
it's not random they pull me off to the
side and say you're going to have to
wait here while we screen you and I was
like I can't see my bag and they were
like your bag's fine sir when I got my
bag expensive USB was gone from it and
they said don't know what you're talking
about and that's it so it's going to be
things like this you're going to be
trying to go uh uh you know you're going
to walk through you're you're going to
go to a venue they are constantly going
to put roadblocks in your way because
the issue is not that they will lock you
up as an individual the issue is they
want life to be 5% harder for anyone who
supports Trump and 5% easier for anyone
who does what they want them to do and
then in the long run people will move
towards the path of leas resistance and
give in and give them what they want
they'll make you'll make choices every
day where you say something like do I
really want to go to Bass Pro Shop if I
do you know I'm going to get a social
credit score ding I'll just go to the
mall or something you're going to want
to buy a Bible if I buy a Bible I'll
just I'll just I'm not going to buy one
I'll just see if I can get an old one
somewhere else these are the pressures
they're going to put on you so that they
can control what you do and what your
kids do yeah yeah you guys remember Kyle
sarapin FBI whistleblower who warned us
that they were going after Catholics now
we're seeing this happen on every level
the federal government right now and
it's disturbing but it keeps happening
and you know Christopher Ray will
downplay it the director of the FBI will
downplay it and pretend like it's not
happening or it was just like a little
slip up oh one person did this but it's
not it's happening all over uh the
federal government right now no one's
really stepping in to say much besides
you know this letter from Jim Jordan
thankfully but what will happen we don't
know well bass I wonder if Bass Pro Shop
will even weigh in on this or if they'll
even go after them because ultimately
they're harassing their their customers
and that affects their line of business
doesn't that yeah I don't I don't
imagine they're going to shut they're
not going to say anything at all they're
going to shut their mouths they don't
want to draw they don't want to draw
attention Bass Pro Shop needs to file a
lawsuit and be like hey man like we're
going to lose money because of this yeah
spy on it's a fishing shop yeah you
never been to Bass Pro Shop no got
everything miss the video we got well
cuz they have guns probably is why
they're spying on people oh yeah yeah
that's why most of us pay cash these
days man I don't think that matters I
know they still F you I I I I've been
seeing this coming and in the age of
quantum computers with Quantum
encryption hacking they're going to be
able to break encryption real easy and
like go back for the last 20 years of
your encrypted stuff and then make that
stuff in in the database too it's a part
of why I don't type a lot about politics
on the internet I don't like it in text
I'd rather it just be I speak it with my
voice of course artificial intelligence
is going to be able to pick up video
chat chat and talking and stuff but it's
I I have self-censored righteously I
think like I don't want to I don't want
to Virtue signal my political beliefs
and text I it's almost like I just I've
seen the writing on the wall I know that
this technocracy is is is knocking at
the door right now knocking at the door
I think we're through the door already
it's it's they've been inside the house
for a while but they're still knocking
like there's more than one of them I
mean we're going on almost two decades
now 2024 this all starts in the social
media era in the 2000s that's my con
that's the thing I'm most scared about
is is is the the idea that all of the
things that you need for like a digital
prison or whatever are already in place
and already turned on before people even
realize it like with the the whole thing
with AI like if AI becomes aware of
itself before people are aware you know
like that kind of that kind of situation
where like it just kind of happens like
everyone got their phones like plugged
into their into themselves like you
didn't realize that you were going to
get addicted to it but everyone just
kind of did and now you're dealing with
the consequences and I'm afraid that's
going to happen again something that
kind of has worked me up and freaked me
out is when CLA Schwab about three
months ago said the biggest threat to
the New World Order is
libertarianism and I was like what the
hell what is he all sudden it's right in
plain sight they're like this is we
finally said the thing that for 20 or 30
years you've been that we've been
pretending like we're not saying that
libertarianism was that like an American
political ideology Liberty it's just
just it's it's the the purest uh
individual first kind of political
philosophy that you can come up with I
think is probably a good way to it it's
older than this new technocracy so I
don't see how this old methodology could
be a threat to something new the new
thing has the burden of proof on it it
it has the burden of requirement to show
that it's better than what we had before
the past can't threaten the future well
it's not even the future though all the
stuff they're talking about collectivism
these are not new ideas these are very
old ideas the problem is it relies on
electricity all this stuff relies on
electricity all this whole technocracy
this whole Global spying Endeavor if the
power goes out we're back to like
Grassroots yeah but I mean EI the
impulses that they have like the the
kind of like you know centralized top-
down power centralization stuff like
that doesn't need electricity they did
that in the Soviet Union with like when
it first became the Soviet Union there
there was no it was a peasant you know
they were all Farmers an agrarian they
didn't go through the the normal uh you
know capitalism and then to Socialism or
the the what Mark said Mark said that it
was be capitalism and socialism they
jumped from like the Stone Age to like
modern times so like and they were very
brutal and like monarchies are known for
being very at least past in the past
very brutal if you spoke out against the
king get your head cut off kind of thing
so like I don't know that they really
are known for that I think that there
were some that were but that I don't
know that I'm sure or there were plenty
of benevolent dictators and and you know
they also wrote the history book so
they're not going to write themselves to
look like evil villains but like the the
the electricity maybe is what keeps
Central Authority peaceful and if the
electricity goes out then they have no
choice but to rule by force Thailand
still has Les magese laws what's that if
you disparage the royal family in any
way you get locked up even you even if
you're quoting someone else to criticize
the CR criticism of the king so like if
you said something like did you hear
what that man said he should be jailed
for saying the king is stupid oh you
said the king is stupid you're under
arrest oh even just forming the words
well that's what that's what I was told
and and people in the country were very
scared to they were like you can't even
criticize the the phrase you can't say
how dare someone say the king is stupid
that's what that's what I was told
that's how serious the law is but uh man
back when I was this like 10 years ago
they loved the king now I don't know
because that's it was King pum Pon a
different King well now it's his son and
his son was considered to be like we we
did it was really funny because we did
did a documentary in uh uh in Thailand
about the king and how he's beloved he
did a lot to help raise the uh literacy
rates and pull people out of poverty so
as much as they were people it was funny
because they were groups that were
protesting monarchy and wanted a
parliamentary system I think they have
one but they wanted to get rid of the
monarchy and they were like all of the
leaders that I met were like the king's
so awesome but it's just time for a
modern era that's the only deal we have
and then there were some people
privately be like I hate the like more
leftists and more like you know but then
when the
Prince was taking over and he's like
seen on video like flying somewhere
wearing hot pants and like doing drugs
and other crazy yeah right it's like a
hunter b i I literally like Hunter Biden
then people were just like okay wait a
minute so we made this documentary and
we tried releasing it we actually had to
structure I get I got a script I was
reading and then after we finished they
come back to me and they're like we need
to reread this line for the documentary
because we we insinuate that there are
people who called the prince a bad name
and this could get people in Thailand
thrown in prison so there's another way
to phrase it instead of saying he's a
drug adult say people view him as
weaker than the Demi godfa that he has
and I was like are you kidding me and
they were like better safe and sorry we
really want to criticize the guy and so
that's how we do it and then we can get
and then the it's it's a it's a
challenge because the documentary then
got massive play in Thailand they all
wanted to watch it and they said if you
insult the prince no documentary sees
the light of day if you say PE it was
something like you can watch it you can
find this line where it's like he is not
the demigod that that his father is is
viewed to be or whatever like that's the
best criticism is that he is but Normal
Man sure I guess all of the talk of
loyalty and and political loyalty and
stuff I'm I'm like I don't understand I
guess the perspective of the people that
are that appreciate monarchy or that
want it and like I a lot of I'm like yo
yo in England like down with the
monarchy like let's start let's start a
Democratic Republic in England let's do
it Now's the Time do in Thailand let's
do the monarchy in the monarchy in
England like they don't actually have
any like significant legislative power
and they're a net benefit uh to the
economy but the king I disagree the king
can disband Parliament yeah the uh and
the King uh approves the royal family
approves the Prime Minister I
think I think it would be be naive to
assume that when the was it the Civil
War in the UK I'm not big on UK but they
like Civil War and then they're like
okay okay okay we got to we got to split
power and create the House of Commons
and let people have some say in this
yeah all that was was the king being
like how do we prevent a revolution
where we get our heads chopped off let's
tell them whatever they want to hear we
actually will still control the Reigns
of power and uh everyone's got to pay
the royal family the royal family is
super wealthy super rich I I I I firmly
believe behind the scenes the king the
Queen the royal family can do whatever
they want whenever they want and control
everything it's like saying the clintons
have no real power the clintons to this
day are still orchestrating things
behind the scenes and and and uh uh and
and putting massive pressure so I'll put
it this way to the people who are like
the monarchy has no real power it's like
do you think Obama has power right now
he was an elected guy now he's not in
office no everyone still thinks he's
pulling the strings so don't come on the
Royal Family's pulling strings some
people say the Obamas are the most
protected Americans on earth like
they're the ones they're the the power
family on Earth the Obamas of people
Perhaps Perhaps should be thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net